so you just discovered Juneteenth huh
welcome join us this hottie is sacred
and as a proud black girl from Texas it
is an honor to share why this holiday is
important why it's necessary and why it
must be protected at all costs it means
so much to us and it's important that we
uphold its legacy June teen June 19th
also known as Freedom Day commemorates
June 19 1865 when Union Major General
Gordon Granger but federal orders from
the headquarters of the district of
Texas and Galveston and forcing that all
previously enslaved black people and the
westernmost Confederate stronghold were
finally free however this was two years
after the Emancipation Proclamation had
formally freed slaves when the American
Civil War had largely ended with the
defeat of the Confederate states Texas
had a low presence of Union troops so
the enforcement of the proclamation was
slow and inconsistent the first
Juneteenth celebration took place in
June 1866 with Church field gatherings
full of food music and fellowship and
soon enough the gatherings began to
spread across the south but buck joy but
arts music food and black liberation
taking center stage today we normally
see local gatherings especially in the
south uplifting and celebrating this
holiday but the holiday deserves to be
celebrated across the country black
people deserve to experience joy and
black people deserve to celebrate
Brazilian black people deserve to feel
black people deserve to be free America
has a long history of racial injustice
natural celebrate Juneteenth this year
may we honor those who came before us
souls who were beaten up
and just farted to the sides discarded
and stripped from their families may we
have lived those who persevered and
maintained their sanity
maybe we uplift those who never had the
chance to live to see today the day that
they were free Juneteenth deserves to be
a national holiday we can so easily
celebrate holidays like July 4th and the
freedom of America but we deserves to
celebrate those who built this country
those who made sure that America could
exist the only uplift America we have
lived those who built this place
Juneteenth must be a national holiday
and it must be respected at all times
now go cash up your favorite black
person $100 ok we deserve
[Music]